[Music]
delighted to have you back on the show
your third appearance on the show I
think the last time you were on was at
least deep about a year and a half ago I
think you know at this point lots of
lots has happened since then
you got this new book coming out which
we're going to talk about your body and
balance which is all about hormone
health and the impact of nutrition and
lifestyle on hormones and the downstream
impact of that on everything that we're
interested in here but before we dive
into that because it's so topical and
and and top of mind even though we're
recording this well in advance of this
coming out I think it's important to
talk about this which is this study that
came out recently that made headlines
across the world that in so many words
basically said keep eating meat there's
no link between your meat intake and any
kind of disease so walk me through this
study how those headlines came to be and
your response to it it was such a crazy
scenario what happened was the annals of
internal medicine published six articles
from one research group headed by a guy
named Bradley Johnston and right in
Canada you Trevor X right who directs
whatever that is so the first four of
these six articles were meta analyses so
there's nothing new what they do is they
took existing research and crunched it
in a new new way and what they found in
these four articles was if you reduce
your meat intake you actually do cut
your risk of cancer cut your risk of a
heart attack cut your risk of stroke and
diabetes and that it's not chance it's
not it's statistically significant
meaning it's very unlikely that this is
just some chance result however he did a
fifth article where they looked at
preferences and values and they looked
at prior studies of meat eaters and they
concluded meat eaters like meat right
and in fact they think they need me of
course he had a lot of meat eaters I did
where do I get my protein that kind of
thing so then they did a sixth article
which was what do we recommend and what
they recommend I'm not making this up
they said the reduction in cancer and
heart attack and stroke and diabetes
isn't worth it if you have to give up
meat and so they recommended continue
eating meat including the most unhealthy
forms like sausage and bacon the ones
that are clear-cut human carcinogens and
the I have to say I'm gonna point a
finger of blame at the journal the
annals of internal medicine because they
were the one that back in I think was
2014 remember Time magazine had that
cover story with butter on it a big
swirl never I'll never forget that it
said eat butter that was back same
journal same journal II published and
equally not so good meta-analysis saying
they couldn't sort out the risks of
saturated fat so go ahead and eat butter
and then in 2016 2017 they published
another article saying sugar is okay and
that was by the way the same author
whose Johnston Joe Johnston Johnston
Johnston
and it then came out that he was taking
money from the food industry it was like
a whole battery of conglomerates that
included coca-cola and ConAgra etc he
did disclose that did he'd make the
disclosure with that study though I yes
I think so yeah I think so but somehow
it was sort of reported in the press and
it was a while before you know if you're
gonna say that dr. pepper is good for
you look who's paying for it
mm-hmm so they were kind of disgraced so
then this new thing came out and the
reason I'm gonna blame the journal is
that the annals of internal medicine did
not say these meta-analysis show that
reducing meat would actually help you
and if you want to reduce me it will
help you oh by the way this was just the
benefit of reducing what if you stop
eating it completely the benefits are
even even greater and they didn't dive
into things like yeah meat eaters might
think that they need it or it's a source
of protein but there was nothing about
what if you educate people is the is it
not true that people are in fact
changing their diet I mean look at the
marketplace veggie burgers everything's
just taking off so anyway they should
have press release and the press picked
it up saying new guidelines is there
were no new guidelines this is just
Johnston's
idea and that you can just continue
eating need for good health and I have
to say I contacted the editor and she
said you know you're right we went a
little too far with that will change I
don't think they did change it at all
well a couple things first of all wasn't
there an initiative or an effort to
prevent that from being published in
that Journal
I had a time because I think I'm on that
email chain that I believe you're on as
well from David Katz and there was like
a you know like how can you know before
it was published there was an awareness
that this was going to be coming out and
an effort to let this journal know that
this was going to be irresponsible the
journal sent out this press release the
journalists started calling experts the
experts were disgusted by this they said
we you're completely misinterpreting the
science here and so David Katz and many
others us lots of others wrote to the
journal and said think this through a
little bit before you say that people
should keep eating meat look at your own
science and look at the body of science
they just ignored that ignored it I
don't know if I don't know if it was
clickbait or if there's some of the
reason journals do want a lot of
controversy and the press they like to
have their name out there because it
improves their what they call their
impact effector compared with other
journals but then when we dug into it a
little deeper the New York Times did a
story saying hey wait a minute this was
the same guy right was funding for the
sugar so like a couple weeks later that
can of this article came out right but
what didn't come out at the time and
what did not make the headlines is that
just six months before this article came
out Bradley Johnston had signed a deal
with Texas A&M University's AgriLife
Program which oversees all their beef
promotion programs and I know that that
your listeners have never heard of this
but it was very troubling Texas A&M
University in Texas they promote beef
and the head of that group is a guy
named Patrick Stover who signed an
agreement with Bradley Johnston and came
on to the project and became a co-author
and when you look at their disclosure
forms when you do research you have to
disclose your conflicts of interest and
they say things like are you getting
money from anywhere
the answer's no is there anything even
aside from money that could look like a
conflict of interest like you run beef
promotion programs for example no they
wrote no none of that none of that came
out yeah I sorry to interrupt but I as I
recall from that Times article the
letter of the law was that you have to
disclose any conflicts of interest in
the last three years right and he had
had a deal that same deal that he had
that was with respect to that sugar
study that he did that had expired
shortly beforehand so I was a little bit
outside of that window so he his
response was well that was more than
three years ago I wasn't required to
make that disclosure but but that's not
in the spirit of what this provision is
which is to basically say listen you
know is there anything that you've done
or or you know that could potentially
compromise these findings that's right
and this new this new thing was totally
current it was current at the time and
that was not in the New York Times
article the New York Times didn't pick
it up and what I'm saying is big the
beef industry signs or not the beef
industry Texas A&M University which gets
beef checkoff money and promotes beef
heavily signed an agreement with Brad
Johnson's group six months later they
come out with this study saying eat beef
you don't want to give up beef do you
and then the press goes well new
guidelines I guess and it was it was
really a sad situation so what maybe I'm
mistaken but wasn't part of the study
based on this built-in assumption that
people were only are typically only
eating meat like three times a week so
for their guidelines to suggest like
keep doing what you're doing is
disingenuous because most people are
eating me like 20 times a week I mean
they're eating it probably twice a day
they may be and and their own research
did show that if you reduce meat
consumption or you eat very little meat
you do better than if you eat a lot and
our research and that of many many other
teams show that if you just throw out
the meat completely replace it with
healthier food so you do dramatically
better so there was really not much
question about getting away from meat
was is a good idea but it was just the
way that they characterized it in the
guidelines that
up with which were really meet friendly
mm-hmm so in the wake of this this this
article getting published in this
journal there was a bit of a kerfuffle
you know that resulted in these New York
Times articles but also I think there
was like 12,000 physicians that came out
against this American College of
Cardiology and of course you at PCRM you
guys filed a petition with the FTC so
explain to me what that's all about the
Federal Trade Commission regulates
advertising and a press release that
goes out to the press to sell your
journal until your website that's
advertising so we went after the annals
of internal medicine we filed a
complaint with the Federal Trade
Commission to say when you advertise
yourself saying you've got new
guidelines that you can keep eating all
the meat you want whatever we said that
that's harmful to people and it's also
false now it may sound like it's a bit
reaching to try to get the annals to be
dragged to the FTC however we did
exactly this with the dairy industry
some years ago when they were
advertising if you're trying to lose
weight and dairy is part of your diet
you'll lose more weight than if you're
trying to lose weight and dairy isn't in
your diet remember you might remember
these ads that you know dairy helps you
lose weight well if there just was no
good science so and and the Federal
Trade Commission ruled in our favor on
that so we're gonna do the same now
right so what's the status of that at
the moment at the moment the FTC has it
on their desk yeah we'll see what we
hear it's so crazy I saw a tweet the
other day from the Dairy Council or some
milk affiliated organization that's a
that said something along the lines of
milk is better for hydration than water
to me like if that's I don't understand
how that could possibly be but that
seems like a flagrant you know violation
of FTC guidelines regarding advertising
there's lots of goofy stuff and I have
to tell you that goofy stuff comes out
on the cycle if it's a five-year like
2000 2005 2010 2015 2020 that's when the
goofy stuff comes out mm-hmm because why
Dietary Guidelines for Americans are
reformulated every five years and so
what we've been seeing is the
articles saying new studies show that
eggs are good for you there should be no
restriction on dietary cholesterol
dairies good for you eat butter so that
was in 2014
going up to the 2015 guidelines revision
so what they're trying to do now this
Dietary Guidelines Advisory Committee is
meeting in Washington and they're gonna
say what kids should eat in school and
everywhere else and so the beef industry
the dairy industry the chocolate
manufacturers everybody is pushing on
them with their guidelines that
emphasize their product and then the
reporters dutifully parrot this message
and all that goes on that's a problem I
mean that's interesting so it's very
much like a presidential campaign here
we are in the lead up to this 20/20
scenario in which the guidelines are
going to get revamped and there are
vested interests that have a lot to gain
or lose based upon what ends up in those
recommendations I'm pleased to tell you
that Ukraine was not involved in this
suffice so you know we don't know but
but it I have to say it is disheartening
because we all imagine journal editors
are sort of above the fray and they just
want to have the truth come out and that
they're not out there Hawking an idea
and whatever but it's it's been creepy
to see I have to see yeah well if
there's one thing I've learned from our
social media infused culture it's just a
hyperbolic the diet and nutrition wars
are and the front lines are being waged
on Twitter and you see these the vitriol
that goes back and forth between these
respective tribes and camps and it's you
know as somebody who's relatively
steeped in all of this I get confused
and I and I wonder like who's you know
who is being buttress by who and who's
telling the truth and can we really know
with nutritional science what you know
with any sense of veracity what isn't
true what is fact and what isn't or you
know it and so for the average consumer
I mean you know confusion is the product
like the average person is just going to
be left thinking like I can't trust any
of this stuff because everyone's
slinging arrows at each other all day
long
confusion sells the medians that the
tobacco industry proved this the jury
was in and out yeah there was no
question that tobacco caused cancer but
if the tobacco industry could have some
studies saying well there's some doubt
here some doubt there they don't have to
prove it safe confusion is all you need
to sell and if you can say well what
they did say in this case bacon sausage
these are the things that slam-dunk the
the World Health Organization said they
caused colorectal cancer period these
new articles said well we're not 100%
sure there's the data are limited and
whatever so the confusion really sells
yeah what do you make of this whole
carnivore movement have you been paying
attention to this at all and probably
more than it deserves I think this too
shall pass yeah it's fascinating what's
going on right now and I think it's more
incumbent than ever before for for all
of us to pay closer attention and and
read the news with a critical eye and
also look for consistency of findings if
somebody tells you vegetables are not
good for you or you know an apple is
going to hurt you or beans whatever I
mean there's certain common-sense things
that we know and the scientific studies
are so clear and so uniform from
observational studies to randomized
clinical trials and everything that a
plant-based diet is a healthy diet the
closer you get to an entirely
plant-based diet the better off you're
gonna be
well here we are you're on the precipice
of releasing it's like your 15th book
right yeah you're a busy guy which is
amazing so explain to me what drew your
attention to hormonal health and while
you've chosen to put a lens on this at
this time rich I stumbled into this
completely by accident you know because
we think about food as affecting your
weight or your cholesterol but I was
sitting at my desk one day and my phone
rang and it was a young woman who said
dr. Bryant I can't get out of bed I said
what's the problem and many women have
some menstrual pain but for maybe 1 in
10 or so it's off the scale cannot
function for a day or two days and this
was her she said my mother told me I
should call you and you could help me
and so I said well I can give you some
painkillers for a couple
days but I started to think about what
are what are cramps and menstrual cramps
to put it simply are the lining of the
uterus is being thickened up every month
in anticipation of pregnancy and it's
hormones it's estrogen that does that
and if you have extra estrogen female
sex hormone that uterine lining thickens
up a whole lot more and at the end of
the month it all is disintegrates in
menstrual flow but as it disintegrates
that thick lining releases
prostaglandins that cause cramping so
she's telling me her symptoms I thought
wait a minute I wonder if you got too
much estrogen in your blood somehow and
it ran through my mind that I remembered
from physiology 101 that your liver has
a way of removing estrogen it takes it
out of the blood your liver filters your
blood it pulls it out and sends it down
through the bile duct into the
intestinal tract and as long as there's
plenty of fiber in your intestine it
just flushes all that estrogen away the
excess if there's not fiber in your
digestive tract because you ate Velveeta
for lunch then those estrogens go back
into circulation and your your estrogen
level stays too high so I said to her
how about this let's try an experiment
I'll give you painkillers a couple days
but for the next month would you like to
try a diet that might might help no
animal products keep oils really really
low foods as natural as possible
four weeks later she called me back and
said this is astounding my period came
zero symptoms nothing and then in the
months that followed same story but then
she loosened up her diet a little bit
the pain came back so I thought okay
that's one person so I I connected with
our friends at the Georgetown University
Department of OB obstetrics and
gynecology and we did a research study
we brought in a large group of women
they all had moderate to severe pain
every month we split them into a placebo
group effectively and a vegan group and
it works on the first thing they notice
is that PMS was was different
bloating and water retention cut way
down and then mood changes that they had
been bothered by were reduced and then
when we tracked their pain
it was fewer days and less noticeably
less intensity
so we thought okay that's that's really
important but but rich I gotta tell you
something
in the course of this study we told all
the women please don't take any hormonal
preparations in the course of the study
because it's going to goof up our
results and that includes birth control
pills so if you're sexually active
please use some other method because we
don't want the hormones to interfere one
of the women said don't worry about me
my husband and I gave up trying to have
a baby years ago it's not him
we've been tested it's me I don't
ovulate she just was not releasing eggs
on any kind of ridiculous the second
month that she was on the vegan diet she
came in and said dr. Barnard I've got
bad news and I've got good news I said
what is it well I'm leaving your study
because I am pregnant and she was
pregnant and about eight years later I
was giving a lecture in a different City
and I didn't realize she had moved she
came to my lecture and told me about her
three kids what I'm saying is that
hormones affect pain they affect
fertility they affect hormone related
cancers like breast cancer prostate
cancer so many things and everybody is
ruling these dials on their hormone
levels by the food choices they make
every day without having any conception
of what is what is happening so the
reason I wrote your body and balance is
I thought well let's get your body in
balance because all of these things make
people miserable it's some cases they
just make you miserable in other cases
like hormone related cancers they can
kill you so let's get this information
out there and yes if people want to buy
prescription drugs fair enough if you
need to have a hysterectomy for
endometriosis maybe but if we can if we
can just change your lunch and your
dinner and do it like that let's do that
yeah I mean those are some pretty
dramatic results so walk me through I
mean the first example that you gave was
the impact of increasing fiber into that
person's diet but there the study that
you conducted was going full vegan so
those are two different things so let's
maybe talk about just nutrition in
general and its impact on hormonal
health and kind of
Maran she ate between those two things
okay um the reason that we went full-on
vegan is I gave you one example of fiber
but it's not all there is to it
this whole area started being studied Oh
20 years ago maybe more poor for cancer
patients breast cancer patients have one
thing on their mind
which is I don't want my cancer to recur
and so researchers have looked at
dietary changes that reduce estrogens
for cancer patients and they found two
things the first is fiber which I
mentioned earlier a high-fiber diet
flushes these estrogens away quite
literally but the other thing is fat
animal fat and even oils vegetable oils
for a reason that I don't know the
mechanism we haven't figured it out if I
take a group of women and I put them on
a fatty diet their estrogen levels rise
and you can do both together you could
say high fiber low fat low you know high
fat low fiber and you could see estrogen
levels going up and down and up and down
very rapidly so we thought okay I don't
want any animal fat in your diet at all
that means it's vegan but we went a step
further and kept oils low uh-huh so what
that means is that everything you're
eating has fiber everything you're
eating is from a plant there's nothing
in your diet that's not a plant and so
you're getting abundant fiber very
little fat and we thought that would
work the best and right it does right so
high fiber low fat Hulk basically whole
food plant-based diet and over the
course of this book you kind of go
through a whole battery of different you
know maladies that I think are really
[Music]
affecting so many people right now I
mean breast cancer is like one out of a
true man or something that prostate
cancer is one out of every nine men in
fertility rates are insanely high right
now there's lots of opinions about
what's contributing to that beyond
hormonal health weight gain thyroid
moods hot flashes you know endometriosis
which you mentioned menopause acne
fibroids like the whole the whole thing
right so you make this decision to
divide this book up into basically
different categories the first is
related to sex hormones and fertility
and ovulation the next relates to
metabolism and mood so why don't we just
like go through it I mean we talking a
little bit about sex and hormones right
now but this fertility thing is super
interesting I mean I know I'm sure you
know you know tons of couples that are
having trouble conceiving
and IVF and the like are are you know
things that you're just hearing about
more and more and more all the time
and I think there are a variety of
contributors and some may have nothing
to do with diet that's possible or they
may have to do with chemicals you're
being exposed to without being aware of
it but diet is a big part of it one of
the obvious things is that people are
gaining more weight than they used to
and they're gaining weight earlier we
see a lot of kids where childhood
obesity has become a thing and if you
look at when at what weight is your
fertility the best it's actually not
when you're a little bit overweight a
personal I think wow if I'm overweight
that's gonna be helpful in some way that
when fertility for women is at its
highest it's on sort of the thin side of
normal with it you don't want to be
overly thin that's not good but you
definitely don't want to be overweight
fertility is impaired and why would that
be because fat cells are not just little
lifeless bags of calories they are
hormone factories and this is also true
in men if you go to the beach you see
overweight men with their shirts off and
they've got some breast development and
that is because as they've gained weight
their own body fat is making estrogens
causing breast tissue formation so in a
woman
you need a certain amount of estrogen
you don't need a huge boatload because
that will interfere with fertility and
then there's a dairy connection which
completely blew me away
the dairy in this case it's not that
it's there are hormones in in dairy
there as you know they're estrogens in
dairy and that's probably part of it but
the sugar in dairy products lactose
breaks down in your body to release
galactose it's breakdown product and
that's toxic to the ovaries it's linked
to ovarian cancer it's linked to
infertility
and the most amazing thing if you look
at countries that have the least dairy
intake they tend to have a pretty good
preservation of their fertility in a
woman who's from her late 20s to early
30s she's gonna tend to maintain her
fertility you go to a place like the
United States where people consume a lot
of dairy there's this enormous drop in
fertility between the late 20s and the
late 30s and it goes right along with
galactose intake so my point is dairy
doesn't do the body good yeah wow that's
amazing so in terms of addressing that
you you have dietary protocols but
there's also life studies like look you
got to exercise you got to lose a
certain amount of weight there's a whole
section on on chemicals which I want to
get into as well because I think that's
a big part of this that people don't
talk a lot about but what was amazing is
the reversals that you're seeing I mean
this book is filled with all these
anecdotes of you know patients that
you've treated where the turnaround
times are really quite rapid one yes
they are in the menstrual pain study
that I described briefly where the women
their pain improved that was in the
second cycle you know in eight weeks
time will you get better if you go to 12
weeks and Sue sherry 16 weeks yeah
absolutely but that the changes are
quickened and one of those stories true
story that I have really been struck by
was that of a woman named Katherine
Lawrence who was in the Air Force
went to Iraq in 2003 she designed
military bases and when she got back
home her friend said Katherine what all
did you miss when you're over in Iraq
which foods
did you miss and she missed cheese so
she had a friend who gave her I'm not
making this up 48 boxes those little
blue boxes of macaroni and cheese uh-huh
for 48 days straight she ate mac and
cheese dinners that her friend pay for
so anyway she gained weight and she
started to get pain in her abdomen and
it got worse and it worked and worse
than it and it worsened with her cycle
in particular
and so eventually her doctor did a
laparoscopy were you looking to the
abdomen with a little scope and he gave
her diagnosis and the diagnosis is
endometriosis that's where the lining of
the uterus is shedding cells that travel
up and implant all around the abdomen
and they cause pain because they swell
with your cycle but they also will
strangle the fallopian tubes causing
infertility anyhow a lot of women have
will have a trace of this for some women
it is debilitating yeah miserable I'm
talking about fistfuls of ibuprofen
don't get you through the day and
hysterectomy is basically the protocol
that's often that's what was recommended
in her
and if painkillers and hormonal
treatments don't work that's kind of
your option and in fact she scheduled
her hysterectomy however before she
could have it a friend of hers said
Katherine let's try a diet change that
maybe this will help you well she went
low-fat vegan that was basically it and
started almost immediately to get better
like you like you're saying rich that
that it wasn't a long time and week by
week she was feeling better and better
and better she went back and had another
laparoscopy so the doctor looked around
in her abdomen and then sewed her up and
the doctor went out to the waiting room
to find her husband and said this is
really amazing the doctor said her
endometriosis has effectively
disappeared
and her husband said I'm not surprised
you know she went vegan completely
completely changed her diet and she's
been feeling better and better and
better and the doctor said no no no no
no no it can't be that they can't be
that the diet doesn't cause him if
something was wrong with you it would
definitely be because of the vegan diet
but if something's good it can't be that
the doctor said there's only one
explanation for this this must be a
miracle so the doctor I think wrote
miracle in her chart and she never she
doesn't have a endometriosis in you
anymore it went away she never had the
hysterectomy she has three children now
and in fact she joined the physicians
committee's Food for Life group and
Katherine Lawrence lives in Dallas and
now teaches other women how to take back
their their health now let me be clear I
I do want to say a word for not
everybody necessarily gets better
they're all kind and life is not fair
and there's some people who may have
endometriosis or cramps or fertility
issues or what
we're a diet change only does so much
good or maybe not at all those people
should not feel ashamed they're not
doing it right or something our bodies
are fragile things go wrong with it all
the time just like your car it's not
going to last forever for any of us but
we've got some tools that are so cool
and and my message the message of your
body and balance is let's use foods to
get you into balance not a pill yeah
not something else let's use diet and
lifestyle I was just speaking with
somebody the other day a woman who is
struggling to to lose weight and she
feels like she's doing everything right
and she was telling me how she was gonna
go get a hormone panel done to try to
figure out if there was something else
that that she wasn't seeing or wasn't
being addressed so talk to me about the
the implications of your hormones being
out of whack hormone haywire as you call
it on waking and the inability to shed
pounds we've done a number of research
studies where we have compared various
kinds of diets and the one that seems to
cause the most consistent weight loss is
one that has really two characteristics
one is it avoids the animal products but
the other thing is we do have to keep
oils really low and that's an important
message because many people will look at
but I'm gonna call good fats like
avocados and nuts and things and they
are good fats but if a person is
struggling with their weight those foods
happen to be really calorie dense and
it's super easy for your body to absorb
it some people can eat those foods with
no difficulty at all but some others
they'll just find that that their weight
loss starts when those foods are really
minimized - another piece of this though
there's some folks who they go to the
doctor I've really had this unexplained
weight gain or I just can't can't lose
it and my energy is not hot not really
very hot and my hair is changing there's
something wrong wrong wrong with with
how I feel the doctor says I think I
think we need to do a blood test and the
doctors comes out with a diagnosis of
hypothyroidism and your thyroid is at
the base of your neck
and your thyroid regulates your
metabolism if your body needs more
energy or thyroids the one that's gonna
give it to you and if your thyroid is
not behaving you just don't have energy
you can't you your your metabolism isn't
stuck in first gear
and 99 times out of 100 you get a
prescription for thyroid hormone and
what I'm gonna say is that we know a lot
now about what actually is causing this
and it's not a deficiency of that
prescription so what is causing it if
you could look around the world the
biggest reason is a lack of iodine and
in America it's a little bit different
but just looking worldwide it's a lack
of iodine and iodine is in the ocean and
seaweed has lots of iodine in it and so
if you're eating your seaweed salad or
you're having your vegan sushi that nori
around it at the wakame and your miso
soup you're getting all the iodine you
could ever want around 19 in the 1920s
there was a lot of hypothyroidism in the
United States that was solved by iodized
salt the Morton Salt Company said let's
put iodine and that kind of wiped it out
for the United States however it didn't
eliminate hypothyroidism from other
causes and the biggest cause now is
actually an autoimmune reaction where
your body thinks there's some invader
and you're you're like a bacterium or a
virus and so your body is making
antibodies to destroy whatever that
invader is your body will make
antibodies if a virus comes in and you
knock them out right but in this case
there's there isn't a virus and there
isn't a bacterium there's something that
got in your body that you're reacting to
and those antibodies then go to the
thyroid and attack your own thyroid
gland it's the same as in rheumatoid
arthritis you're making antibodies says
something and those antibodies destroy
the synovial lining of your joint and
these autoimmune reactions there are
many many of them they can affect your
skin all kinds of stuff so we started to
discover that there were people whose
thyroids were clearly off I mean they
were hypothyroid they then make a diet
change and they're leaving certain
things out and there are thyroid
condition
goes away now this is a completely new
frontier I have to tell you about a year
before I wrote this book I know I would
not have said that this is possible
uh-huh except that I've met so many of
these people and what we here's what we
believe is happening what we believe is
happening is that the dairy proteins and
other proteins are regarded by the body
as foreign they are for it and so your
immune system recognizes them as foreign
develops antibodies against them and
it's a those antibodies that end up
attacking you it's the same process in
type 1 diabetes a little kid 8 year old
kid is fed cow's milk not not mother's
breast milk milk from a cow body says
wait a minute that's foreign I used to
attack it makes antibodies to attack
those foreign proteins those same
antibodies then destroy his own insulin
producing cells in the pancreas there's
a we need more research on that but
there's a lot of evidence that that's in
fact the case kids who don't consume
cow's milk have a lot less risk of type
1 diabetes so in the case of the thyroid
these antibodies do two things they can
turn it off hypothyroidism in some cases
they turn it on too much hyperthyroidism
so what we're what I think we need to do
is a lot more research studies now yeah
where we go into endocrine offices and
instead of handing out prescriptions
left and right we take 6 weeks 8 weeks
12 weeks and just see to what extent
getting that junk out of a diet can cool
down this autoimmune reaction yeah it's
interesting that there isn't more
research on this I mean you open the
book by saying these are very recent
findings a lot more work has to be done
like your your your it's not a
disclaimer but you're saying like look
we're learning as we go here and this is
kind of a new frontier but it seems like
this would be something I mean
hypothyroidism is something that affects
a lot of people all these things are and
in certain areas that we've talked about
we have plenty of information diet and
breast cancer I would view now that it's
a slam dunk that a woman diagnosed as
breast cancer would do very well to
follow a completely healthy plant-based
diet and frankly before the diagnosis
ever occurs we should use that kind of
diet to prevent it with regard to the
menstrual pain that I described we have
done of
very careful randomized clinical trial
that shows the diet works so I don't
think anybody's gonna say that that's
not true but but some of these areas
like thyroid and also mood how food
foods affect everybody knows that
hormones can affect your your mood and
how moody those moody days of the month
and all that kind of stuff we did a
research study at Geico the car
insurance company because their their
headquarters the other in DC right it
didn't air they're in DC area they
they're right there about three blocks
from my office and so years ago we
decided to do a study together where
anybody at Geico who wanted to do a
vegan diet to lose weight or to improve
diabetes we'd help them do it and in the
course of it it was an 18-week study and
people just would you expect happen I
mean they lost weight their diabetes got
better but along the way we asked
everybody to fill out just
questionnaires on how they felt they
didn't know what we were looking at but
what we were looking at was mood
depression and anxiety and both of those
seemed to remit to quite a substantial
degree they weren't brought in for that
reason they did these were just people
who wanted to do better now part of that
could be that I'm losing weight my
diabetes is in better control I feel
better
that's true the other thing though is
that diet affects your gut your
microbiome and if I repopulate your
intestinal tract with friendly bacteria
those bacteria are no longer making
nasty stuff that kind of affect the
brain yeah well that the the nexus
between the microbiome and the brain is
really fascinating and that that seems
to be you know on the fan guard of
emerging science and it's pretty cool to
see what's coming out from people that
are looking at that I hope that we look
into it much much more there have been
some very good researchers who have put
this to the test independent from what
we have done bringing in people and
tracking their mood and changing their
diet in a variety of ways and I have to
say I hear again I think we need more
research but what we have seen is quite
consistent evidence that people on
plant-based diets do feel better
specifically with regard to reductions
and anxiety and reductions in depression
we also found reduced absenteeism but
the ketogenic diet seems to have the
reverse effect where people seem to feel
worse now they're glad if they're losing
weight or something like that but it's
not a die
to get the brain back into mmm into
better function hmm one of the things
that that you go into in detail in
addition to increasing your fiber in
your diet and reducing the fat you you
get real specific on on the oil thing
you know we're in a moment right now
where there's a lot of confusion about
about oils and healthy fats and this is
a healthy oil as if we're suffering from
an olive oil deficiency or something
like that widespread acceptance of this
notion that you know coconut oil is a
health food so talk a little bit about
that and also this part where you
discuss omega-3s is problematic which I
thought was interesting and I hadn't
seen anybody kind of talk about that in
that way oh you guys we all think about
omega-3s is the healthy fat that we need
that were you know if anything that's
the one we're trying to get more of well
they are you need the body has a need
for two fats one is alpha-linolenic acid
and that's an omega-3 the other is
linoleic acid and that's frankly
everywhere so you're not going to get
low on that but alpha-linolenic acid is
in lots of seeds and and plants of
various kinds in your body lengthens it
into the other omega-3s that you need
like DHA for the brain and so some
people have said well you know that
lengthening process is pretty slow and
so maybe I should take fish because the
fish have the preformed DHA mm-hmm in
them and they've been trying to sell
this for all kinds of stuff and frankly
it hasn't panned out very well for the
fish oil sales people because DHA
supplements don't really seem to reduce
heart risk and at least so far they
haven't been very effective against
Alzheimer's and whatnot however
researchers have discovered something
really kind of frightening which is that
if you have too much DHA in your blood
or or if you're supplementing for men
prostate cancer risk goes way up and at
first this seemed like a fluke because
funny things can happen in studies that
you don't expect but it has shown up
consistent
enough that the researchers now believe
it's real but we don't know we don't
know why we and I can't explain it but
the bottom line is if a person is
supplementing DHA we suspect that at
least four men that their cancer risk is
gonna be higher and they might say okay
when I rather get cancer would I rather
get Alzheimer's and enter and and
honestly I don't know the answer to that
to that question yet but but I think
nobody can fault you for saying all
right healthy omega-3s their implants
and if I consume those and I don't
consume a lot of competing oils at the
sixes yeah yeah potato chips anything
that's that's got cooking oil soaked
into it those things compete with your
natural omega-3s for the enzymes that
lengthen them so you don't wanna have a
lot of other oil and in fact if you use
no oil at all in your diet no it no
added oil there's still natural traces
of oil even in green vegetables that are
proportionately very high in omega-3 so
if you're eating lots of greens you
don't think of that as being an oil
source but it's it's a it's a source of
the natural oils your body thought
you're gonna have right so then as a
takeaway no supplementation of omega-3
or an algae based one or do we need do
we not need to do that if a person does
supplement DHA and and the case can be
made for supplementing it and some have
made the case and the case is this that
if you look at people whose blood tests
are show they're low in DHA they're at
higher risk for Alzheimer's than other
people so some people would say get you
could get tested you can call up
laboratories and send them a drop of
blood if you in fact just google DHA
testing they'll send you a test kit and
you put a drop of blood on it and
they'll tell you if you're lower high if
you decide to supplement DHA I would
definitely do it with a vegan source if
you go online there is vegan DHA it's as
good or better than the fish ones and it
doesn't make you smell like a fish
market but whether it's gonna help or
not is something that future research is
going to have to show that we don't know
yet
all right let's talk about testosterone
you know I'm 53 now and in my peer group
I've got lots of buddies who
are either taking exogenous testosterone
or considering it and this is like a
thing right so walk me through what's
going on with men's hormonal health in
the sexual context yeah um well a lot of
things are going up the first the first
issue is not even testosterone it's that
men are exposed to estrogens a lot um
the guy goes to the fertility clinic
we're having trouble could you evaluate
me too and if you check Hanks sperm
count if he's a big cheese eater he'll
have tend to have lower sperm counts
then his friend who doesn't eat any
cheese and what's that about it's not
that he's low in testosterone
he might think that's it it's not it's
because the cheese has estrogens that
came from the pregnant cow at least
that's what we believe is going on
because you see reduced sperm count
poorer morphology which is the shape of
it and poor motility the sperm just
don't they don't grow or disposed to
swim very fast yeah they're having
trouble getting organized and it and it
just starts with a relatively small
amount of cheese just a serving or two
of regular high fat cheese's per day
will do that and so some guys will say
well it's got to be soy that soy gave me
the man boobs and all that kind of stuff
and soy gets a completely not guilty
verdict verdict on this as I'm sure you
know that first of all women who consume
soy have about 30 percent lower risk of
developing breast cancer than women who
don't have soy and women who have had
breast cancer who consumed a lot of tofu
and tempeh and miso and whatnot they
have about a 30% reduction in their
likelihood of dying of their cancer so
soy is as a cancer preventive it does
not cause man boobs if anything soy is
sort of a break on estrogenic function
soy soy has isoflavones that attach to
estrogen receptors but just like your
car has a gas pedal and a brake pedal
soy although it will attach to the
estrogen receptors it's not stepping on
the gas it seems to be stepping on the
brake so what about testosterone I
honestly don't know what to make of
this yet and science is marching forward
because a lot of guys are taking
testosterone and you'll see commercials
do you have low tea could this be why
our investments aren't rising could this
be why you know you're having a bad hair
day you know I mean I'm kidding but but
it's about like that like if you just
take more testosterone everything's
gonna do better and what we've been
worried about is are you are we going to
be fueling prostate cancer by by
injecting or by having guys take
testosterone and from I don't know yet
whether that's true or not I I would say
this that in theory a high-fiber diet
you would think it would reduce
testosterone levels because your body
filters out extra testosterone sends it
down the testing tract fibers should
carried away except for the fact that
when you look at guys on healthy high
fiber diets their testosterone levels
are high stay tuned we're gonna sort
this out at some point mm-hmm we know
that erectile dysfunction is an early
arbiter of arthrosclerosis but let's for
the sake of conversation assume heart
this there's an individual their heart
is perfectly healthy they don't have any
arterial damage but they're experiencing
erectile dysfunction or their there they
have low libido what is the hormonal in
our interplay there and what have you
learned about that yeah well
testosterone does play a role there
that's for sure but to tell you the
truth it really is cardiovascular
disease in the vast majority of cases
the guy goes to the doctor it says doc I
can't raise the flag and that people
have wonderful my problem is there's
nothing wrong with my nature and the
doctor has to the doctor can give out a
viagra prescription but that is a
complete mistake if the doctor doesn't
also give him a description of what's
going on in his body which is that
atherosclerosis effect all the all the
major arteries of the body and the
arteries that go to a man's private
parts just happened to be smaller
narrower than the ones that go to
through the coronary arteries that go to
the heart muscle or the cottage that go
to the brain so people will correctly
i erectile dysfunction as the canary in
the coalmine it's a sign that something
is wrong and so if a man has man mid-50s
it starts developing erectile
dysfunction this is not performance
anxiety and it's probably not a hormonal
issue it's probably the beginnings of
atherosclerosis in that area and it
means he's got it in his heart too and
he's got it in his carotid is going to
his brain and so that is a man who needs
to read Caldwell Esselstyn book or Dean
Ornish's book and and reverse that and
in our research studies where we put
people and vegan diets for diabetes or
whatever the men start raising their
Flags at home probably not out in public
oh yes the point the point being that
when you reverse reverse arterial
disease erectile dysfunction gets better
too one of the things that you talk
about in the book that I had never heard
before was that lower back pain is
indicia of our thorough sclerosis and
that freaked me out because I got a
little bit lower back pain well there's
lots of reasons to have lower back pain
and you're entitled because you're an
athlete well you have a you have
punished your body more than just about
anybody else but as you know you you
break it down and build it right back up
um but yeah this this started it started
out with smoking that researchers looked
at smokers and they have more back pain
than non-smokers you think wait a minute
cigarettes are not heavy what the heck
could this be yeah and is it just makes
them lazy and they're sitting around all
day what it is researchers did autopsy
Studies on people who had had lower back
pain in life and after they died of an
accident or whatever they looked into
their lower back and what they found was
amazing the the aorta comes off your
heart and it rises up and then it does a
u-turn goes right down your back and in
right in front of your spine and your
aorta gives out blood supply a blood
supply to your spine the lumbar arteries
feed every lumbar vertebra the very
first place where atherosclerosis Mladic
changes occur is in that lumbar a Horta
and by around age to 18 or 20
people have paved over completely paved
over one of their lumbar arteries it's
just gone
so smoking encourages anthros karate
changes so does meat-eating and so if
you don't get blood supply to the lower
back then the discs that are the
leathery cushions between the vertebrae
they are in a precarious position they
get fragile and just like a pillow the
inside
smooshes out because of its now fragile
it's like a rupturing pillow and then
that the the contents of the discs push
against nerves and give you pain so my
point is that if we don't smoke and eat
a healthy heart healthy diet it can
reduce the risk of lower back pain yeah
it's amazing because I you hear about oh
I have a ruptured disc or my disc
rupture and I always thought well that's
because of your posture or the way
you're sitting or some kind of muscular
atrophy or imbalance in your body I mean
it can also be sitting in your Rambler
at a stoplight and a semi
tractor-trailer runs into you all right
oh all these things can happen but your
ability to heal is impaired if you don't
get blood and oxygen and nutrients into
your tissues and you need a good blood
supply to carry toxins out right so yeah
let's talk about skin and hair I know
you know I've heard many anecdotal
stories over the years when I got rid of
dairy my skin cleared up which seems to
make common sense because you're
removing a product from your diet that
is infused with natural hormones and
probably artificial cleanse as well but
talked to me about you know the hormonal
systems that contribute to the health of
those two things when Japan back in the
1960s 70s Japan had a diet based on rice
and if meat was used at all it was not
in these big hunks it was little bits
that were used just to flavor the rice
or flavor their noodles and then when
McDonald's arrived and the other fast
food chains arrived and and meaty
business lunches became the order of the
day the rice content of the diet didn't
diminished and it gave way to meat into
cheese and researchers started to notice
a bunch of things there was more breast
cancer more diabetes more weight
problems
but also dermatologist started to report
that there was more hair loss and wait a
minute
what is all this about and we we still
we still don't know all the details on
it but it looks like like it might be
aggravating the age associated hair loss
the hormonal changes from from diet our
aggravating age-related hair loss is
that true who knows my mother used to
always say you know out of my four boys
you're the only one who kept his hair
and I said that's cuz you're a
vegetarian all your brothers are bald if
they're listening they they have they
have a very don't worry they're not
listening they might be yeah I kept my
hair longer than they did I still got a
fair amount of it's like a pretty thick
every time I see you you get younger so
whatever your oh keep saying that rich
anyway who knows yeah but we've but we
the skin is strongly affected by what
you eat the hormonal changes with hair
loss could be part of it but then with
regard to the skin itself I think it
could be something different I think it
could be not not so much estrogens and
testosterones I'm guessing it could be
more inflammatory conditions that if you
look at acne it's just little
inflammations all up and down and a
number of people have found that when
they follow a healthy plant-based diet
it goes away now I want to stay tuned on
this because I will see some people
where they go in a vegan diet and
especially getting away from dairy their
skin just clears up miraculously I've
seen some other people who say they feel
that for them it's salt or it's oils or
other things so I think it's good to be
open to different things contributing to
to these but it's quite clear that it's
it's a response to something in the diet
for many people the the case study that
you use in the book is Nina and Randa
they wrote their own book they did
basically teenage girls mutual friends
of ours and the acne that that they had
was pretty severe right and the reversal
was was profound they were miserable
with it and and I mean any kid is
self-conscious but they were also
performers you know musicians and if
we're not going to have a good stage
presence but
them it was V that the answer was vegan
and low fat so they scrupulous he got
rid of the fats and that seemed to to
help them enormous lee so what can you
say
I encourage people to just put it to
work and and try it out mhm because when
you look at cultures that haven't have
not westernized there very few left but
they did not seem to have much acne
until the cheeseburgers and right comes
out yeah one of the things that that
I've been struggling with lately
is is sleep like I've been traveling a
lot I'm waking up in different places
all the time I'm on the move and my
sleep despite best efforts and this
crazy routine that I have to ensure a
restful night is becoming more and more
elusive and I know that it has to be
related to my hormonal health or
something being out of whack so what if
what have you learned about not only the
importance of sleep but how lifestyle
and diet impact sleep and what's going
on kind of hormonal II with that yeah
there's a bunch of things going on let
me maybe start and I'm not going to talk
about you i'ma talk about other other
other folks because some of this won't
apply to you
first of all people are having all kinds
of trouble sleeping you are not alone
but for anybody else I'm gonna say
number one start with caffeine and and
look at that because even if all you
have is a cup of coffee in the morning
different people eliminate caffeine at
different rates and for a lot of people
about a quarter that cup of coffee is
still circulating in your brain at nine
o'clock at night and so it doesn't mean
you can't sleep but what it means is
your sleep will be lighter and will be
more easily disrupted and then number
two is alcohol a lot of people will
unwind with a glass of wine and that
will make them fall asleep but in the
middle of the night your liver
transforms alcohol into something else
called an aldehyde acetaldehyde and it's
a stimulant and so four o'clock in the
morning you'll wake up and it's kind of
driving the brain and it's a certain
kind of awaking it's not that beautiful
isn't the early morning hours isn't the
wonderful haha it's this kind of creepy
feeling of having poison in your system
and the more a person drinks the more
this happens so those are just things I
would recommend to anybody else to think
about but physical activity is is really
important none of this relates to you
rich because your voice the caffeine
does I drink caffeine in the morning I
have a cup of coffee right here because
now I'm in that thing where it's like I
didn't sleep well last night so you need
to my deals come in I gotta be on my
game oh thank you yeah um physical
activity is important I mean there are
some people where all day long all they
do is this you know they're we're gonna
thumbs on their their handheld and they
get Noah you know at no exercise they
they're reading a book and then they
close it and try to sleep there but if
your muscles are tired they demand sleep
its asleep is not just for your brain
it's for your muscles to allow you to
stop moving you're supposed to just be
turned off and let's repair so if a
person has not had physical activity I
encourage them to do some some squats
and push-ups something to just strain
your muscles a little bit before you go
to sleep and you'll find it helps the
next thing and this will sound
completely cuckoo but bear with me if
you look at your dog or your cat it's
getting toward evening and they stretch
out their leg and they do a big on and
then they curl if they go to sleep and
you look at your child does this exactly
the same thing they go through all this
things are stretching on they do this
kind of preparatory thing for going to
sleep I don't know why it works but as
adults what do we do we're watching TV
we click it off and we put our head down
and we don't go through them so when
nobody is watching if you're having
trouble sleeping when nobody is watching
do this a half hour before your sleep
time stretch out your arms in a huge
stretch and open your mouth and make a
big yawn it will be totally fake it
won't be real but you're just doing it
going through the motions do that four
times and it will become real and you
will notice that for some reason it
turned on the sleep mechanism but now I
know that sounds cuckoo but try it
you'll see and the last thing let's talk
about neural hormones in the brain
neurotransmitters one of these is called
serotonin and serotonin is involved in
mood it's involved in sleep
if a person eats a lot of protein of any
source it prevents serotonin from
getting to work and so you'll find that
you have more trouble sleeping and this
is why people discovered on their own
that if they're having a kind of a carb
heavy meal and the dinner they sleep
better
so if I have pasta and I have rice but
I'm not having super high protein things
I sleep better and the reason is that a
high carbohydrate diet allows serotonin
to become active in the brain and
improves sleep yeah it induces that food
coma basically yes well that is is all
the blood going to your digestive system
is it not and then um partly but but you
know that some of the food coma is a
different thing when people talk about
say the post Thanksgiving dinner food
coma that's not that is not from the the
tryptophan in the turkey creating
serotonin that's because they ate all
that grease that got into their blood
and their blood is now so viscous their
their brain can barely be oxygenated
that that's really that kind of food
coma but but let's say you wake up in
the middle of night it's 2:00 in the
morning go to the fridge and just pull
out some bread and have a couple slices
of just plain bread lie down and the
serotonin will just be formed and you'll
doze right back to sleep mm-hmm how dare
you suggest we eat bread I think yeah I
think bread is amazing it beats the heck
out of sleeping pills well let's kind of
carbohydrate we'll do it we'll do the
same thing let's talk about grains I
mean grains have been demonized there's
this you know idea out there that we
should be removing all grains from our
diet and eating this Lokar you know
protocol so what say you I say nonsense
first of all if you look at the
populations around the around the world
that live the longest the blue zones
where this comes from Dan Buettner great
work where he they marked in blue all
the places on the map where people lived
a long time their dietary staples are
never meat not even fish it's always
some kind of grain product legumes and
so forth talking about Okinawa Costa
Rica Loma Linda California where they
lots of vegans and then if you look even
further back we are not carnivores we
are great apes along with chimpanzees
gorillas orangutans bonobos they are not
eating ice cream they're not eating pork
chops they don't eat meat
at all with rare exceptions they're
phenomenal amounts of fruit that's their
big thing and they'll eat leaves and so
forth so we are designed in my view to
be herbivores now the fact that people
can lose weight on a ketogenic diet is
simply a sign that carbohydrates are a
lot of what we eat if you take all that
away
you are going to lose weight if you take
away anything you eat you're more likely
to lose weight but it's not a healthy
way to do it tonight we touched on mood
a little bit ago but I think it's worth
diving a little bit deeper into
depression because you know we are mired
in a bit of a mental health crisis
depression rates are through the roof
and there's lots of ideas around what's
generating this loss of connection and
community and you know our addiction to
our devices and our sedentary lifestyles
etc but what does it look like from a
hormonal perspective first of all it
should be said that while it's true that
stresses can can work on our brains
there's no question about it and life is
stressful for lots of people but
depression is not just something
psychological where my feelings were
hurt or I've had a loss and so I'm
miserable depression can be just
flat-out physical and we learned this
decades ago with a drug called reserpine
it's an anti antihypertensive drug is
for to lower blood pressure and people
were put on this drug their blood
pressure came down but there are moods
which sometimes just collapse and what's
that about well it turns out that the
the compounds that affect blood pressure
like norepinephrine for example will
also affect mood and you take them away
it's just like letting the air out of
your tires so that led us to think all
right if it's not just life events but
it also can have something to do with
physical things well what am i doing
myself with more than anything else that
you're dosing yourself with foods and
one of the most shocking
research studies came out of Scandinavia
where they looked at women who had
postpartum psychosis this is this is an
off the scale serious and mental problem
the woman has given birth to or three
days later she starts to become
delusional she's hallucinating her brain
is just unplugged very very serious
condition and the researchers discovered
through blood tests that the women had
what are called K zoom orphans in their
blood kasem orphans come from milk
products and we've identified them in
she if a woman eats cheese or milk the
casein protein breaks down to release
these morphine like compounds that
attach to the brain and can cause a
variety of effects in this case it was
the woman's own breast milk that they
had given birth their body started
making breast milk and some of it was
leaking into their blood breaking down
to release k so more funds that were
poisoning their brains had caused him to
be wildly while the psychotic so that
the take-home message here is not don't
give birth the message here is is that
case orphans are serious business so I
just described a really off the scale
bizarre situation what about the person
who's just dosing themselves with these
things a little bit every day two or
three dairy servings there are some case
of orphans in milk when milk is turned
into cheese there's a lot more of them
and if you look at the rise in cheese
consumption over decades it's parallels
the rise in obesity and the rise in
mental health issues and all kinds of
other things I'm not saying there aren't
other contributors there are but I have
been struck by the fact that people are
eating foods that frankly cheese is
loaded with saturated fat so it slows
you down it's going to interfere with
your athletic ability because your
muscles just can't oxygenate if you got
Vaseline in your blood but the chemicals
in it can affect the brain directly have
there been studies that have directly
looked at the implications of certain
types of foods on levels of depression
yes there will have been
not enough but there have been studies
that started out as observational
studies looking at kind of like our
Geico trial where we brought in people
for other reasons and just notice their
moods get better
researchers have brought in people
specifically looking at their mood and
found that if you compare a person on a
vegan diet a person on a pescetarian
diet a person on a meat-based diet the
vegans tend to have lower levels of
depression and lower levels of anxiety
there's still all kinds of reasons to be
miserable particularly if you're vegan
every 5 seconds someone is going to say
where'd you get your protein you're
gonna get tired of that and so there are
reasons why is even you depressed we
labor with these with these things but
the vegans tend to do better and then
researchers have done it as a randomized
clinical trials not big enough not long
enough in my view but what they have
found is that when you start a person
who is not on a plant-based diet on a
plant-based diet and you don't tell them
what you're looking at but you track
mood it tends to improve and improve
rather rapidly mm-hmm
there are a lot of people myself
included who are running and gunning all
the time feel like it's indulgent to
take a minute for yourself and this
results in kind of a persistent state of
chronic exhaustion that we kind of
colloquially call adrenal fatigue but
what is
adrenal fatigue what are the adrenals do
what is it renal fatigue and how can we
address that or a sidestep that well the
adrenals are they get their name because
if their adrenal you renal is your
kidney and adrenal means they're on top
of it so they make a variety of hormones
that affect they make sex hormones and
they make other other compounds that
regulate your body chemistry and the
theory is that you're under stress and
so your adrenals are running out of gas
just trying to keep up with you and that
eventually they just collapse from what
you're doing and so the answer is to win
the lottery quit your job moved to to
Bali and everything's gonna be great
maybe the next best thing is to eat in a
more in as healthful way as we can I do
I do think that that food is
also not all there is to it I think we
do need to sleep we do need to get some
exercise but then give our bodies a
chance to just recoup we do need a
certain amount of fun in life I say this
is a person whose abysmal at practicing
these things only because I face the
same challenges you do but I do have
some rules that I live by and one is
always vegan keep it low fat and no
matter where I am or what I'm doing when
the clock strikes ten I go to sleep yeah
you can hold yourself to that it's it's
a really hard thing to do but I'll get
up early if I need to it just really
helps because what you discover is if
you're up till 11:30 and it's 12:00 and
it's 12:15 you will discover if you
track the next day you're you are not on
your game as well as if you've gone to
sleep at 10 yeah I found as I age that
I'm a little less resilient yeah I'm
very much a creature of my habits and my
routines and when I'm at home and I can
control my environment a little bit
better that I do really well and it used
to be if I go out of town and I'm kind
of throwing off my thing like I can roll
with it
but I'm finding that I'm becoming less
and less and less able to do that like I
have to be much more conscientious about
these things and create healthy
boundaries when I'm on the road or when
I'm in circumstances where I don't have
as much domain over my schedule yeah and
you're not alone in that although I have
to say if you look at kids kids
sometimes do terrible with that you put
them in a different time zone there
they're just comatose they can't deal
with it at all
and don't have sleep they'll have like
sleepover parties and stay up all night
and they'll be kind of fine you know
like they get over it quick yeah so
anyway I think it's important to respect
these these diurnal variations that we
that we have yeah other than making sure
you're in bed by 10:00 what are some of
your other habits and routines around so
that's it I always have breakfast I
always cook myself breakfast and one
other little trick that I might mention
for some people even though fruit and
other carbohydrates foods I think are
perfectly fine for health for some folks
I find that there's a mood boosting
effect to having specifically some plant
protein early in the
and early in the meal what I mean is
this let's say my breakfast I started
off with with some grilled tempeh or
some tofu or something like that and
then follow that with some green
vegetables or some oatmeal or whatever
it might be I find that I personally
feel more balanced than if I didn't have
that plant protein ahead of it and
people can try this and see if it works
for them and the the opposite example is
in France where people start every day
with just a pastry or something like
that and and a really dysfunctional way
of doing it is to do it with sausage or
bacon where it's protein but it's a big
mixture of protein and animal fat and
cholesterol and glop that does more harm
than good
but with plant protein starting off
earlier in the meal and earlier in the
day I find that my energy is is better
mm-hmm for the rest of the day not not a
lot just just a tiny little bit right I
like that I'm gonna I'm gonna try that
yeah I mean I found something if I eat I
can't do some kind of very carbohydrate
rich meal early in the day I feel like
it it takes a lot of energy for my body
to digest that and I just don't feel
ready for that but if you if I eat
something that's higher in protein it
just it doesn't give me that heaviness
and I feel more energetic more quickly
yeah you might like go to breakfast it's
it sounds crazy if I'm if I'm on
somebody's program other than yours rich
and they asked me what did you have for
breakfast I have to sort of make it up I
blueberry pancakes something that sounds
it something sounds normal but the truth
is I'll start off with some grilled tofu
or tempeh and then I'll have broccoli or
Brussels sprouts and I load them up with
Bragg's or vinegar something like that
and then I'll have a papaya which
growing up in North Dakota I never had
papayas and so I'm making up for lost
time now and the papaya is very high in
carbohydrate the tempeh is very high in
plant protein and the green vegetables
are and in between there right and I do
that every single every single day it's
so exotic I like it it sounds it sounds
goofy but I find it works for me let's
talk about the chemicals section in this
book I thought this was super
interesting some of it you know kind of
conventional with with not conventional
wisdom just sort of widely accepted
common sense but some of them are
a little bit you know kind of a scan sin
that I wasn't super familiar with them
so it starts off with you talking about
the perils of BPA which we all know like
all the plastic that proliferate right
daily lives so talk a little bit about
that yeah it started out with Progresso
soup
you know Progresso is good soup you know
it sounds a little Italian it's got to
be a notch better than the other soups
in this soup aisle you know the cans are
even bigger so progress a lot to be good
so researchers gave Kenneth enough
Progresso soup to some research
volunteers and they had them eat it
every day and they found BPA in in their
blood
I'm sorry in their urine at ten times
the normal level well BPA is as you said
it's it's a compound that's used in
plastics but it's also in the resin that
lines the ke liner yes in the liner of
the can and researchers separate
researchers have said if you look at men
who consume a lot of it there they seem
to have more sexual dysfunction and the
idea is it's probably an endocrine
disruptor
so Progresso has heard about this and by
the way they're not alone if you go to
the health food store you'll see cans
marked bpa-free can and all the others
that don't say that probably have a BPA
in them but Progresso has issued a
statement saying ok ok ok we'll
transition toward the bpa-free free cans
but that is that the oh well I can tell
you another thing you go to the store
and you buy your bpa-free can of green
beans or soup and you walk out holding
the receipt that you would sign your for
your credit card the thermal paper has
BPA in it too and it passes right
through the skin and so researchers have
looked at people who are like a cashier
where every 5 seconds you know they're
handing another receipt to somebody else
and they're BPA levels in their body
will rise from that so from now I'm sure
that everybody now is going to go to the
store and they're going to freak out
about a can that's not marked bpa-free
and they will refuse to take the receipt
from the cashier that's it throw that
away I don't want to touch
it's not just receipts it's um ATM
tickets everything that's printed in
that way that's their note that kind of
shiny thermal paper that's that's BPA
but that's not all
frankly I'm just concerned about what
people have talked about for years which
is just pesticides pesticides are used a
lot and you can see why you go to the
grocery store and every orange is
identical and they look fabulous and
they're beautiful and and there's no
insect damage to them because they've
been treated by best designs I think it
does pay to buy organic I don't think
it's even a question some people say is
it worth it to get organic wait a minute
someone's going to give you this food
that has chemicals in it and this food
that doesn't what's the Trice and the
chemicals used are used specifically to
kill things kill life on the plant and I
think there's this idea that if you wash
them it's fine but this seeps into the
root systems and it's absorbed by the
plant it's inside this plant itself yes
now the Environmental Working Group has
done a good job of of saying all right
which are the worst foods and and the
list will change from from year to year
but if you go to the Environmental
Working Group website you'll see the
latest list but the rules of thumb are
that if it's a fairly fragile plant one
where you could imagine the insect going
to the spinach leaves are just tearing
them up as opposed to maybe a cantaloupe
or they have more difficulty the the
more fragile plants are the ones where
you really want to get organic because
that's where the farmers are using
pesticides to stop the ladybugs from
from going to them and the other thing
is if it's a plant where you throw away
the peel it is true that in some cases
it's inside the plant in other cases it
could sometimes things are added like
waxes to kill fungi and things like that
those are on the surface and if it's a
grape you're eating that skin if it's an
orange or not so you can you can use
these kinds of decision makers but if
there's if there's organic always always
always I always get that and the extra
value of organic products is by law
Organic
things cannot be GMO so you get organic
tofu
it is not GMO if you get chicken that
chicken has been eating GMO soy that
chicken has been fed all over life yeah
and you you can be GMO free and not
organic
conversely yes so it gets tricky but i
agree with you i mean if you if you want
to learn more about that organic that
that list you can go to e WT orga
believes the website just felt that
Dirty Dozen
you know straw strawberries are always
going to be at the top of the only buy
organic list whereas like an avocado is
going to be something it's going to be a
little bit more safe if it's
conventionally grown right exactly and
by the way if you cannot get organic
this that does not mean you should not
eat vegetables
if inorganic vegetables are the only
ones you can get if if the asparagus
there just happens not to be organic it
beats the heck out of spam one of the
things I have a hard time wrapping my
head around is and I've heard you talk
about this I've heard dr. Michael Greger
and Caldwell elseis didn't talk about
this is is the benefits of frozen fruits
and vegetables because they're I guess
because they're frozen shortly after
being picked and somehow that locks in
the nutrient value of them but to me it
just seems like weird to buy frozen
vegetables and fruit that are in plastic
bags as opposed to I guess if you can't
get organic or you know I don't know if
that's not available to you but what it
what are your thoughts on that III agree
that that getting if something is frozen
shortly after harvest that it may retain
better nutrition compared to something
that was picked a long time before
you're gonna and that's in something
good music distribution cycle before and
you know some things aren't gonna
disappear if you get some some greens
and I don't care how old they are or
whether they're frozen or not the
calcium in them is not going away the
iron in them is not going away those are
elements and they don't degrade
what does degrade is some of the
antioxidants like vitamin C it's for
and it will degrade over time the other
thing is for me I'm at home for a day
and a half and then I'm gone again
so I find it handy to have frozen
broccoli in the right in the you know
free round kale and you're in your
pantry
I find it handy for that and you can get
frozen things that are organic and so it
works fine talk to me about citric acid
this was news to me yeah this was news
to me too um citric acid is something
that you would think sit well first of
all is in everything yeah that's the
thing it's everywhere it's it well it
gives a little tangy flavor and you
think that comes out of a lemon or
something like that what it does is it
comes out of fungi in China it's it's
genetically engineered product and most
of it comes from Chinese factories and
it's believed to be potentially toxic we
first started to notice this I was doing
some migraine studies and this isn't
funny but I it just blew me away
there were people in our studies who
said it's citric acid and I thought no
they have a soda was citric acid it
triggers the migraine so that cannot be
because we imagine it coming from
Florida it comes from a lime or
something it doesn't it's this weird the
issue here is that there's citric acid
in it but it's contaminated with
mushrooms that are used as part of the
genetic that yes part of the the GMO
production of it and so the belief is
that that's what you're reacting to so
then you decide well I don't know if
it's healthy or not I'm gonna try to
avoid it and then you will be blown away
by the fact it is in everything
so anyway stay tuned I think we're gonna
learn more about that right so so Maya
meats but walk me through like what does
it do it what do we know what it's doing
I mean what it what is the hormonal
dysregulation that's being caused by
ingesting this um with with regard to
migraine we don't know exactly but we've
migraines used to be thought to be
related to
the circulation of the brain will change
rapidly that the blood this is
completely naive but the blood vessels
tighten up and then they relax and you
get this terrible headache
we now know that has nothing to do
that's not the whole story if it's part
of the story at all
we now believe it has to do with perhaps
changes in the electrical function of
the brain the depolarization of the
brain and our question is whether citric
acid is tinkering with that mechanism
who knows
stay tuned but there's no need for it in
the diet just in the same ways there's
no need for BPA in your soup I think
some of these some of these chemicals
will probably get a not guilty verdict
others will be but I think it's good to
be on the side to err on the side of
caution um one other thing I think
should be said there are some people who
are worried about chemicals so much that
they think that if they just have a
steak that doesn't have chemicals or
they have cheese that doesn't have some
added chemical that that must be okay
reality check the animal products are
bad for you whether they have added
chemicals or not and then the the
sprinkling of additional chemicals that
that aggravates the problem well if
they're feeding on GMO crops all day and
and feed that has you know been grown
and fertilized soil then even though
they may not be in fort of yes you know
injected with hormones there's still a
vehicle for that there's that but but
yes and I agree with you completely but
there's one other thing beyond that and
that's to think of this a cow is a
machine a pig is a machine if we start
with let's say we start with soybeans
and I can take those soybeans and I can
grind them up and make soy milk and I
can drink that and a person might say
that's processed you took the soy beans
you sent them to a factory the factory
ground them up and put them in a carton
I could take the same soy beans and I
put them in a trough and they let a cow
eat them and the cow eats them and it
goes down the cow's esophagus it gets
into the cow's intestinal tract which
processes it in its own way and then it
turns it into milk and so milk ends ends
up in the cow's udder this is a
gene producing this milky goo with
estrogens added and cholesterol and fat
and other things and lactose sugar and
then it comes out and then you eat that
my point is we recognize a factory as a
machine the cow is a machine in her own
right - and I don't mean to be
disrespectful to cows but the most
processed food of all is is dairy and is
meat you take a chick and and a chicken
and you feed the chicken grains and
whatever and then the chicken lays an
egg and and whatever it was in that
grain ends up getting dramatically
changed into feathers and and beaks and
liver and all kinds of stuff and then my
point being that animal animals no no I
get it and a you know fish our great
example of of how they can consolidate
and condense you know the toxins that
are in our ocean and then store them in
their bodies and deliver them to human
beings when they eat them in these you
know toxic forms because they're so
consolidated Dairy is the same way that
that toxins tend to get into dairy into
milk and the same thing tragically
happens in a woman's body if she's been
eating lots of chemicals that will end
up in her breast milk and her first
child is going to get a big load of
chemicals that she has stored up over
the years yeah what was the most
surprising thing that you discovered or
learned right in this book um how many
people are struck by these problems and
how quickly they get better
Lindsay Nixon who maybe no recipes in
them she did the recipes in the book and
she's a genius in the kitchen she does
such a wonderful job and and working
with Lindsay was just super and she has
books of her own that people should pick
up so anyhow I called up Lindsay I said
I want to work with you let's do some
recipes great great great so we did that
she she said by the way I'm one of your
women examples I couldn't get out of bed
I had all kinds of menstrual symptoms
menstrual pain when I went completely
plant-based totally vegan I improved
dramatically and I am just hearing so
many people who have had these issues
and then so many other people who have
the same issues now but
ever tried to put it to work to put a
healthier diet to work so my message is
this whether a person tries your body
and balance reads it and tries it or
they just decide in their own way to get
the animals off their plate to have as
healthy a diet as possible so many
people find that for the first time in
years they're gonna feel good but my
goal is a little bit bigger than that
my goal is if we don't do this your kids
are gonna grow up thinking it's normal
to gain weight it's normal to feel rot
and it's normal to be on medication when
you're 30 it's normal to be in poor
health and if I just give you a med form
and prescription for your diabetes and
synthroid prescription for your thyroid
issues I'm not helping anybody other
than you you know if we can change the
way the family eats you're affecting
everybody together I think that's a good
place to end it but I do have one more
question for you okay what is the study
that hasn't been done yet that you would
like to see be done that could really
you know help reveal certain truths that
we're aiming at right now I think I
think we need to do more cancer studies
and there was a real tragedy done a few
years ago this is really bad on the
woman's healthy eating and living study
brought in a group of women more than
3000 women who had breast cancer and
they randomized randomly assigned them
to two groups one group got five a day
vegetables and fruits and that was
supposed to be the normal group no no
change cuz everybody eats five
vegetables and fruits a day the control
or the experimental group was eight a
day plus juices and then as time went on
they found that when they looked at the
dead who lived and who died of their
breast cancer all the women had breast
cancer to start with and then some of
them went five a day someone ate a day
and at the end of several years they
found that it didn't seem to matter a
whole lot which group you were in and
the researcher said well I guess the die
change doesn't really help that's it
wait wait wait wait wait wait you've got
women who have all have had breast
cancer they volunteered for a study
where you told them we're testing what
vegetables and fruits do and they
weren't eating five a day before none of
them were and you're telling them to
ramp up their vegetables and fruits and
you just
I think it's reasonable to say that five
or eight who cares but to add this to
your diet it is really important and the
study had a lot of benefits from both
diet change and exercise even in the
control group that were good but because
here's the tragedy because the a two day
group wasn't dramatically better than
the five a day group in their survival a
lot of cancer researchers started
thinking let's forget it let's not look
at food let's go back to drugs of
various kind and the desire that women
with breast cancer have that men with
prostate cancer have that that that
families have if somebody's attacked by
one of these conditions their their
desire to get healthy is so strong that
we can put that to work and rather than
using people as recipients of
prescriptions even though we may need
those sometimes let's instead work with
people as partners to help them to put
the the best fuel in their body and see
if we can't get better and I want to see
an investment in that kind of research
that is bigger than than what we've had
in the past yeah okay well thank you for
coming and talking to me well thank you
rich for all you do I have to say people
listen to to what you've said and you'll
never know how many people you inform
and intrigue and inspire and any given
day a doctor might see 20 patients 22
patients to help some of them in any
given day you see a whole lot more that
see they don't see the base they start
there they might be hearing it they see
you yeah you you will never know how
many people you have touched their lives
but it's huge and I appreciate your kind
of shape that well you have the exam
room podcast now so you've dipped your
toe into this world a little bit right
we're learning from your example so
check that out the new book is called
your body and balance hits bookstores
everywhere February do you have a
exhibitory 4th February 4th please check
it out you can learn more about Neil and
our previous two podcast I'll link those
up in the show notes or you can go to a
PCRM dot org right that's it all right
thank you come back again thank you rich
I really appreciate it
peace plants
[Music]